[Musique]
bon
grand merci à tous
[Musique]
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
vous savez ce qui me touche le plus
quand on entre avec françois-xavier avec
tous les amis dans nos salles les unes
après les autres
c'est de sentir que vous avez repris de
l'envié de l'enthousiasmé qui à nouveau
de la fierté qui à nouveau de l'énergie
dans notre famille politique et dans
cette campagne
ce qui me touche le plus c'est de
constater que la campagne la famille
politique qui bouscule les cartes celle
qui partant d'un point qui nous était
promis d' apocalypse et de sorties petit
à petit semaine après semaine progresse
la seule liste ou dans cette élection il
se passe quelque chose où il ya une
dynamique
c'est notre liste des républicains de
l'union de la droite et du centre
et je suis fier de ça je suis fier de ça
parce que je vous l'avais promis et
parce que je vous avais promis qu'on
reconstruirait et je suis heureux que
nous soyons capables de le faire en le
faisant ensemble
l'image que j'ai devant moi et l'image
que je veux pour notre famille politique
c'est celle où en est on à la fois nos
mères
cet ancien monde qu'a voulu vilipender
emmanuel macron celui qui n'aime pas
celui de l'enracinement celui de la
fidélité celui de la loyauté celui de
l'esprit de service celui qui est
attachée à la place de nos communes
merci henri avec tous les maires qui
sont ici celui que je vois avec
l'implication de nos départements avec
notamment françois et nicolas qui
incarnent deux beaux départements dans
lesquels on n'a pas oublié ce qui est
aussi la place d'une france rurale qui
sait d'où elle vient et qui ne considère
pas non plus qu'elle à sortir de
l'histoire et qui demandent juste d'être
traités de façon équitable dans un pays
qui n'a pas oublié ce qu'était
l'aménagement du territoire au moment où
on a créé la république
nos régions valérie autour de tout ce
que vous apportez ici dans cette belle
région du grand est et je remercie jean
du soutien qui nous a apporté avec
vigueur et clarté
pour moi c'était très important et je
tiens à le dire ici dans cette terre sur
laquelle jean veil aussi et puis enfin
tous nos députés tous nos sénateurs
ceux qui incarnent l'expérience à
l'image de gérard ceux qui incarnent les
nouveaux talents à l'image de fabien nos
sénateurs tous tels qu'ils sont ici
gérard que je remercie de son honnêteté
intellectuelle et de sa présence lui qui
a souvent été une grande figure dans les
batailles de notre famille politique
mais aussi philippe françois daniel
jacques sébastien même qui nous est venu
du val d'oise un jeune sénateur qui est
plein de fougue et qui est venu ici
jusqu'en lorraine pour ce meeting venant
du val d'oise
merci à toi sébastien pourquoi est ce
que j'aime c'est parce que c'est l'image
de cette unité que je voulais nous
rendre parce que je suis convaincu que
au delà de ce mouvement qui est en train
de se passer
il y à un message qui nous est envoyé
dans cette campagne dès le début tout a
été fait pour expliquer aux français que
quoi qu'ils veulent quoi qu'il désire il
n'avait que deux options et qu'ils
étaient enfermés dans cette impasse que
certains avaient écrit à l'avance pour
il n'avait que deux options soit on vote
pour le rassemblement national soit on
vote pour en marche et les français qui
n'aiment pas qu'on leur dicte leur choix
qui est un peuple plus politique que
tous les autres qui aiment la politique
parce que chez nous on aime le débat
n'aime pas que dans une élection on leur
dicte à l'avance ce qu'ils ont le droit
de penser et ce qu'ils n'ont pas le
droit de dire et les français regardent
ce choix en étant à la fois perplexe et
écoeuré ils ne veulent pas voter pour le
rassemblement national parce qu'ils ont
vu le visage de marine le pen
de ce débat du second tour ils ne
veulent pas signer un chèque en blanc
pour marine le pen parce qu'ils savent
trop au fond d'eux-mêmes que cela
pourrait conduire au chaos pour notre
pays gère un vrai mais de l'autre côté
ils ne veulent pas plus donner le
sentiment de cautionner un président de
la république qui les a tellement déçu
une majorité en marche qui les a
tellement écoeuré des allers retours qui
ont fait tant de victimes en si peu de
temps qu'ils ont mis le pays dans un tel
état qui ont malmené les retraités qui
n'ont pas permis de redresser
substantiellement notre pays face à la
menace de l'islamisme qui a sous-estimé
la question de l'immigration et qui n'a
rien fait pour remettre la tête à
l'endroit dans nos dépenses publiques
des français qui savent très bien que
les cadeaux d'aujourd'hui seront les
impôts de demain
parce qu'ils ont un président de la
république et un gouvernement qui n'a
rien fait pour remettre les choses à
l'endroit
eh bien les français ne veulent ni de
l'un ni de l'autre
et il faut dire aux français qu'ils ont
un autre choix
il faut dire aux français qu'il ya une
alternative
il faut dire aux français qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe à droite
il faut dire qu'il ya cette union de la
droite et du centre que nous avons créés
il faut leur dire qu'ils ne sont pas
prisonnier de cette réédition du second
tour de la présidentielle il faut leur
dire qu'ils ont un autre choix possible
que le chaos de marine le pen est la
déception des manuels macron cet autre
choix dans la campagne des européennes
c'est celui que nous leur offrons en
démocratie on a toujours le choix
ne tombez pas dans ce piège des
populistes contre les progressistes il y
à un autre choix pour les français est
dans l'europe
cette question là est encore plus
importante dans l'europe cette question
là est encore plus importante parce que
ces deux visions
cette vision manichéenne à laquelle
revient sans cesse le président de la
république est juste une façon
d'enterrer l'avenir de l'europe parce
que les deux sont des impasses
marine le pen est évidemment une impasse
ici dans cette terre nathalie où tu l'a
rappelé vous avez bien des familles qui
trouvent leur emploi et leur pouvoir
d'achat à travers cette coopération
européenne
ici plus qu'ailleurs vous savez bien que
la déconstruction de l'europe serait une
catastrophe
comment marine le pen ne peut-elle pas
comprendre ce qui se passe comment ne
peut-elle pas voir ce qui se passe de
l'autre côté de la en de la manche où le
royaume uni va connaître les pires
tourments perdre l'emploi fragiliser le
pouvoir d'achat pourquoi parce qu'ils
ont écouté les mêmes voies que marine le
pen et que cela les a menés dans le mur
marine le pen propose pour la france une
sortie de l'histoire
elle propose la déconstruction de
l'europe elle propose la déconstruction
de l'euro je combats de toutes mes
forces marine le pen dans cette élection
parce qu'en matière européenne je suis
convaincu que c'est un choix
catastrophique pour la france mais de
l'autre côté françois xavier
bien évidemment que ce que propose
emmanuel macron est tout autant une
impasse il ne comprend pas que les
français sont pour une vision européenne
mais qu'ils s'interrogent sur ce que
l'europe est devenue les français
veulent de l'europe parce qu'ils ont
parfaitement compris que seuls nous
n'étions pas assez fort mais ils veulent
que l'on remette l'europe dans le bon
chemin
or aujourd'hui ce que propose emmanuel
macron c'est toujours plus de l'europe
qui ne marchaient pas toujours plus de
l'europe qui ne marchaient pas regarder
leurs programmes
nous en parlons ensemble tout à l'heure
la première phrase de la première
proposition de la première idée du
programme dans marche commence par taxer
toutes leurs propositions consiste à
créer des organismes supplémentaire des
institutions supplémentaire d impôt
supplémentaire ils n'ont pas compris que
ce que voulait la france et les
européens
ça n'était pas plus de bureaucratie ils
veulent revenir à l'europe des projets
qui étaient l'europe que nous aimions
ils ne veulent plus de l'europe de la
bureaucratie et des normes qui nous
attends tu affaiblis par le passé et ce
que propose de plus ce que propose de
plus emmanuel macron c'est plus
d'élargissement j'y reviendrai
l'élargissement nous a fait tellement de
mal voilà un programme proposé par en
marche dans lequel il n'y a pas un mot
sur l'élargissement où ils font tout
pour que l'on ne comprenne pas vraiment
ce qu'ils ont derrière la tête
est ce qu'ils ont derrière la tête je
vous le dis c'est ce qu'a dit emmanuel
macron à trieste
c'est ce qu'il a dit à bucarest il est
pour l'entrée la plus rapide possible de
la roumanie et de la bulgarie dans
l'espace schengen ce qui est une folie
et il est pour l'entrée très rapide des
balkans à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne alors que ces pays ne sont
pas prêts et que cela n'est pas
raisonnable
nous nos positions sont très claires
nous sommes contre tout élargissement
supplémentaire de l'union européenne
parce que cela aboutirait à fragiliser
avec trop de pays différents et dans
tout cela ce qui me fait le plus de
peine c'est qu'il a isolé la france
moi je crois dans l'entente franco
allemande
je crois dans la nécessité profondément
dans ma sphère que l'europe se construit
dans la capacité à mettre les gens sont
ils à mépriser les italiens il a insulté
l'europe centrale
il est allé dans les pays scandinaves en
leur expliquant comment il fallait gérer
leur économie
eux qui lui ont répandu mais n'êtes vous
pas le dernier élève de la classe
n'est ce pas vous qui pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de votre pays avait
le pire déficit budgétaire de la zone
euro
vous qui venez et avaient
l'outrecuidance d'arriver chez nous en
nous donnant des leçons vous feriez
mieux de commencer par nettoyer vos
propres écuries et d'être au moins un
des rares pays européens qui a été
incapable de baisser sa bête
au cours des deux dernières années
et oui nadine il y a quelque chose
d'indécent avoir un gouvernement qui n'a
fait aucune économie et qui a juste pris
en deux ans 6 milliard d'euros dans la
poche des retraités et qu'il ne vous
rendra pas parce que la réalité c'est
qu'en refusant la réévaluation des
retraites cette année
la réalité c'est qu'en ayant pris une
augmentation de csg
la réalité c'est qu'en laissant toute
une partie des retraités continuer à
voir l'augmentation de la csg ce
président de la république a pris 6
milliard d'euros dans la poche des
retraités qu'il ne leur rend pas et
c'est quand même une supercherie de le
voir ensuite quelques jours avant une
élection comme par hasard envoyer un
petit courrier pour expliquer
glorieusement tiens je vais vous rendre
une toute petite partie de ce que je
vous avais pris parce que je me suis
fait rattraper par la patrouille
quelle triste vision de ce qu'est la
politique française
les retraités ne sont pas des
privilégiés ils ont travaillé toute leur
vie pour leur retraite
et oui nadine il ya une époque où la
france n'était pas isolé cette époque je
ne l'oublient pas c'est celle où la
france et est la présidence de l'union
européenne
cette époque c'était celle de nicolas
sarkozy est à l'époque la france elle
entraînait dans sa dynamique l'union
européenne
alors nous nous avons une lourde
responsabilité je veux vous parler de
cela pour porter notre étendard
j'ai voulu qu'il y ait un trio est à la
tête de ce trio j'ai souhaité que ce
soit françois xavier qui porte ce choix
et je vous remercie vous qui êtes les
militants de ma famille politique de
m'avoir fait confiance
ce choix n'était pas facile eh bien je
vais vous dire ce que je crois et
n'oublions pas cette leçon en politique
les seuls bons choix sont les choix qui
ne sont pas faciles et soit qu'ils sont
applaudis par les commentateurs ne sont
jamais les bons choix
les seuls choix qui vaille ce sont les
choix de courage maintenant vous savez
pourquoi j'ai voulu françois xavier
vous savez quand il ya eu ce débat
france télévisions et qu'on m'a demandé
à chacune des têtes de listes d'exhiber
un objet symbole de ce qu'il voyait pour
l'europe et que je voyais chaque tête de
liste l'une après l'autre sortir un
objet qui devenait de plus en plus
grotesque
je me disais mais comment la politique
française at-elle pu devenir cela vous
aviez la tête de liste du rassemblement
national qui avait sorti une passoire
rouge pour incarner sa vision de
l'europe
vous avez une tête de livre je ne sais
même plus son nom qui avait sorti une
paire de menottes sur laquelle il avait
mis des autocollants jaunes vous aviez
la tête de liste en mars qui avait sorti
du piment d'espelette j'adore le piment
d'espelette mais enfin peut-être que
quand on parle d'europe il ya d'autres
choses à dire et françois-xavier lui a
sorti un livre et qu'elle livre il a
sorti l'iliade d'homère
ce que j'aime chez françois xavier c'est
qu'il remet de la hauteur et qu'il nous
rend notre dignité
c'est cette politique là que j'aime
à ses côtés il y un trio il y à agnès il
y à arnaud qui est ici qui nous vient de
bourgogne franche comté et qui est le
meilleur spécialiste européen sur toutes
les questions de lutte contre le
terrorisme et toutes les questions
militaires et de défense je suis très
heureux qu arnaud soit à nos côtés et il
y a évidemment celle que je n'ai pas
oublié parce que dès le début je lui dis
qu'elle serait là et que j'avais besoin
d'elle nadine c'est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie énormément et je l'apprécient
pour une raison qui est pour moi la plus
importante c'est qu'elle incarne un
repère dans notre famille politique la
droite n'est la droite que quand elle
n'oublie jamais qu'elle doit veiller sur
chacun avec la même attention
la droite doit veiller sur celui qui
réussit parce qu'elle est fière de celui
qui réussit mais elle doit veiller aussi
sur celui qui appartient aux classes
moyennes modestes qui appartient la
france populaire qui chaque jour à
l'image de cette si belle citation de
paix dit que tu nous as lui fait juste
son travail correctement
parfois on prend dans sa voiture et en
allant travailler loin de chez lui c'est
cette droite là gaulliste du gaullisme
social qui sait où elle est à laquelle
appartient nadine morano et qu'elle
incarne dans notre famille politique
moi j'ai toujours défendues nadine parce
que j'aime la voix qu'elle apporte à
notre famille
et à ses côtés il ya marie dominique il
y à guillaume est liée à nathalie vous
le savez si j'ai voulu françois-xavier
c'est parce que je crois que la
reconstruction de la droite ne se fera
pas en baissant le regard une droite qui
assume ses idées sereinement
tranquillement mais qui ne s'excuse pas
de ses valeurs la droite n'a jamais
gagné en s'excusant de ce qu'elle était
et ma conviction depuis le début
contrairement à ce que parfois certains
pensent c'est que ça n'est pas quand on
assume au grand jour qui en est qu on ne
rassemble pas bien au contraire et je
veux ici témoigner devant vous de ma
reconnaissance pour hervé morin nathalie
tu l'a rappelé et merci à toi à l'image
de ce que vous faites avec françois et
bien ce que moi je vois c'est cette
union de la droite et du centre qui nous
porte
dans cette campagne nous sommes bien sur
la liste des républicains mais nous
sommes plus que ça nous sommes aussi la
liste d'union de la droite et du centre
cette union que nous avons retrouvé avec
les centristes qui eux n'ont jamais
trahi contrairement à françois bayrou
qui a complètement trahi ce qu'était la
vocation initiale du centrisme dans
notre pays et bien grâce à cela nous
plantons les graines qui seront nos
victoires de demain et nos victoires de
demain c'est celle qui nous porterons
pour nos municipal qui nous porterons
pour les départementales et régionales
et qu'ils nous porteront pour la
présidentielle c'est ce rassemblement de
la droite et du centre qui dont nous
portons la première pierre aujourd'hui
dans cette élection européenne
merci à toi nathalie et mercière des 207
m
alors nous parlons de civilisation quand
les pères fondateurs ont pris ce drapeau
quand il choisit ce drapeau ils ont mis
les étoiles de la couronne de la vierge
quand le général de gaulle prend la main
d'adenauer et qu'il choisit la
cathédrale de reims que font-ils
ce qu'ils font je vous le dis ce n'est
pas une construction administrative ce
qu'ils font je vous le dis ce n'est pas
bruxelles ce qu'ils font ça n'est pas la
commission européenne ce n'est pas
l'union européenne aussi respectable sur
la soit il ce qu'ils font c'est quelque
chose de bien plus grand ce qu'ils font
c'est un projet de civilisation
ce qu'ils font c'est qu'en s'appuyant
sur nos racines
ils veulent redonner un avenir à
l'europe détruite par la violence et la
barbarie de la guerre ce qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils portent cette interrogation
dans ce moment si difficile pour
l'europe réduite en cendres
comment peut-on assurer un avenir aux
messages de l'europe
pourquoi sommes nous là nous sommes là
exactement pour la même question
nous sommes portés également exact e
mans par le même attachement aux valeurs
de l'europe et nous sommes portés par la
même inquiétude qui nous taraude
est-ce que face à la chine face aux
états unis face à l'islamisme
face à la question du déclin de notre
économie sommes nous condamnés à voir
notre pays et notre continent changé de
nature
silencieusement ou y at il un autre
destin peut-on retrouver un souffle
peut-on retrouver un an vit une envie
alors quand on nous demande quelle
europe voulez-vous nous notre sujet
n'est pas de savoir si on veut une
europe fédéraliste ou si on veut une
europe souverainiste
nous l'europe que nous voulons c'est
l'europe des projets quand on nous
demande quelle europe nous voulons nous
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
qui parce qu'elle sait qui elle est et
capable d'imposer sa puissance dans le
monde
nous l'europe que nous voulons c'est une
europe qui n'a pas oublié son identité
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
civilisation c'est cette europe là que
nous portons dans ce jour de fête de
l'europe plus que jamais
une civilisation une âme pour qu'il y
ait une civilisation
il faut d'abord des frontières des
frontières ce n'est pas un gros mot
quand romulus et rémus fondre hommes il
trace un sillon pour marquer quoi pour
marquer clairement que ce sont eux qui
décideront qui entrera et qui n'entrera
pas à l'intérieur de la cité
les frontières ça définit ce qui est
dehors et ce qui est à l'intérieur
l'europe ne peut pas être une
construction infinie le président de la
république a accepté qu'à partir de juin
comme par hasard au lendemain des
élections européennes
les négociations pour l'entrée de
l'albanie à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne s'ouvre c'est une folie
l'albanie est un pays qui est marqué par
la corruption
l'albanie est un pays dont le niveau de
vie et la situation économique n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec des
standards qui permettent de les intégrer
à l'intérieur de l'union européenne
nous nous exigeons et les français ont
le droit à la vérité de savoir si oui ou
non la france opposera son veto à
l'ouverture des négociations avec
l'albanie
tous les députés qui sont sur notre
liste ont signé une charte d'engagement
ils voteront contre toute décision
pendant leur mandat qui ouvrira la voie
à des élargissements supplémentaires
et de ce point de vue nadine bien sûr
cela suppose d'arrêter et c'est le
projet commun que nous avons avec les
allemands de la cd ou les négociations
avec la turquie une bonne fois pour
toutes qu'on arrête ce cinéma
la turquie n'est pas dans l'union
européenne on arrête les négociations
avec la turquie pour qu'il y ait des
frontières françois-xavier tu en a parlé
il faut aussi qu'elle soit protégée
et oui la vraie générosité
tu aimes cité pegi c'est un auteur
extraordinaire souvent très lucide peggy
avait l'habitude de dire à rien et
généreux comme la fermeté et rien n'est
inhumain comme la lâcheté quand on donne
ce faux espoirs qui pousse toute cette
jeunesse africaine sur ces chemins qui
aboutit à ces visages hagards qui arrive
ensuite dans nos villes en étant
déracinés dans un continent qui a
dépassé depuis longtemps son intégration
cela ça n'est pas la vraie générosité
la seule vraie générosité c'est celle
qui consiste à se battre pour que
l'avenir de la jeunesse africaine soit
en afrique et non pas pour que l'avenir
de la jeunesse africaine soit en europe
ça c'est la vraie générosité le devoir
de l'europe c'est de développer les
universités en afrique c'est de
développer l'économie en afrique est de
faire en sorte que la jeunesse africaine
reste en afrique ça c'est la vraie
générosité mais pour qu'il y ait une
civilisation il faut qu'il y ait un
projet il faut qu'il y ait des choses en
commun à construire pas les normes pas
ces normes absurde étions il ya à peine
une semaine fabien tu t'en souviens sur
une exploitation
alsacienne qui fabrique des asperges et
bien les pauvres pour réussir juste à
faire des logements pour loger les gens
qui venaient pour récolter les asperges
ils ont affaire à toute une série de
normes sur la taille des lits superposés
sur la taille des portes sur la taille
des locaux ils finissent en est
tellement décourager qu'on aboutit à l
inverse de ce qu on voulait faire le
résultat qui ne font même plus de locaux
pour pouvoir loger leurs saisonniers et
on a même réussi à faire d'énormes en
centimètres sur la taille des aspects
mais dans quel pays vit-on dans quelle
europe
vite on stoppe et la france a tort et la
france a tort de se croire plus
intelligente que les autres nous avec la
folie de notre esprit cartésien
ou quand il y à une norme les allemands
ont le bon sens de prendre la norme la
plus simple et nous parce que nous
pensons être les plus intelligents nous
prenons la norme qui décourage tout ceux
qui travaillent et qui entreprennent
stop les normes
arrêtez d'emmerder les français comme le
disait pompidou par contre nous voulons
des projets pourquoi l'europe ne se
concentre pas sur ce projet merveilleux
qui consistera fédérer tous les
laboratoires de recherche de l'europe et
les faire travailler tous ensemble sur
ce qui est un des fléaux du 21e siècle
les maladies neurodégénératives la
maladie d'alzheimer pour toute personne
qu'il a vécu c'est une épreuve terrible
quand vous ressentez au fur et à mesure
du temps qui passe
la perte du contact avec l'être cher que
les souvenirs s'estompent que la
possibilité de dialoguer partager les
moments heureux s'estompe et qu'elle
arrive et vous avez l'impression que non
seulement la mort et venir mais que pire
que ça on vous a enlevé avant la mort de
celui que vous aimiez la possibilité
d'échanger avec lui tu une épreuve
psychologique c'est une épreuve physique
je n'en connais pas de plus douloureuses
dans une famille cette malle
10 d'alzheimer elle peut être vaincue
j'en suis sûr les chercheurs nous disent
qu'ils ont énormément progressé
je croirais à une europe cette europe
des projets que nous aimions qui soit
capable de dire dans les cinq ans qui
viennent nous allons faire de notre
grande cause européenne la recherche de
la réponse contre les maladies
neurodégénératives et contre alzheimer
et que demain l'europe puisse dire avec
fierté
nous sommes le continent qui a apporté
au monde la réponse contre ce fléau
cette europe là c'est celle que j'aime
cette europe c'est celle des projets
c'est celle qui travaille c'est celle
qui cherche et pas celle qui offre à la
marchandisation tout le corps humain
sans comprendre qu'il ya des limites à
l'éthique c'est cette europe à laquelle
j'aspire
et oui bien sûr françois xavier tu l'as
dit l'europe du travail
nous ne faisons plus du social nous
faisons de l'assistanat
nous n'entendons plus la main aux gens
pour les aider à se redresser
ma grand mère avait l'habitude de dire
la meilleure manière d'aider quelqu'un
c'est lui apprendre à pêcher du poisson
c'est pas de lui donner du poisson
chaque jour comment avons nous pu
devenir un continent est un pays dans
lequel il y à des entrepreneurs qui
chaque jour cherche des gens pour
travailler et qui n'en trouvent pas
comment at on pu devenir un pays dans
lequel vous avez des artisans des
agriculteurs des commerçants qui se
donne du mal et qu'ils ont l'impression
d'être les seuls à le faire
vous connaissez mes positions en la
matière la vraie solidarité c'est
d'aider les gens à revenir sur le chemin
du travail
c'est pour cela que je demande qu'on
contrepartie du rsa il puisse y avoir
systématiquement des heures de travail
d'intérêt général
saint gobain pam saint gobain pam et
quelle meilleure illustration gérard toi
qui était battu pour la
réindustrialisation de notre pays
quelle meilleure illustration de nos
folies dans nos marchés publics la
première chose que nous réclamons c'est
la possibilité de pouvoir réserver une
part de nos marchés publics à nos
entreprises c'est quand même la moindre
des choses tous les pays au monde le
font pourquoi l'europe ne pourrait-elle
pas le faire saint gobain pam
ils sont allé installer une usine en
chine et puis un jour les chinois qui
après bien avoir surveillé ce qu'il
faisait après leur avoir pris leurs
secrets leurs brevets après s'être mis à
produire ce que saint gobain pam savait
produire
après avoir installé eux mêmes des
usines en chine capable de faire les
tuyaux ont décidé que maintenant il
était temps de fermer le robinet et ils
ont expliqué à lusinchi était là bas
qu'elle n'avait plus le droit de
produire qu'elles n'étaient plus adaptés
aux normes et que donc il fallait songer
à arrêter de produire en chine et nous
nous avons accepté parce qu'on ne peut
pas commercer comme on veut ans seen on
ne peut pas s'installer comme on vend si
l'on ne peut pas vendre comme on veut en
chine mais en revance les chinois eux
pourrait venir acheter ce qu'ils veulent
en chine vendre comme ils veulent en
chine et la vendre comme ils veulent en
europe et produire comme ils veulent en
europe
mais où est la raison dans tout cela est
maintenant saint gobain pam serait
revendue aux chinois qui se sont
arrangés pour faire perdre des millions
d'euros à ce fleuron industriel de la
lorraine en chine
eh bien je ne me résigne pas il faut
retrouver le sens d'un patriotisme
industriel dans lequel on défend d'abord
nos propres entreprises à l'échelle
européenne une civilisation enfin c'est
savoir qui nous sommes
oui au sort
cette civilisation et fragile parce
qu'elle est attaquée
certains pronostiquaient la fin de
l'histoire c'est tout au contraire le
retour de l'histoire et d'histoire la
plus violente
c'est le retour de cet affrontement
entre les civilisations comment ne pas
le comprendre ceux qui tournent leurs
armes contre nous ne sont bien souvent
pas nés en dehors d'europe et de france
ils sont nés chez nous la france et
l'europe vont tout donner tout leur
générosité
et pourtant ils ont tourné leur armes
contre le pays le continent qu'il aura
tout donné
il déteste tout ce que nous sommes et
ils veulent détruire ce qu'est la
civilisation européenne et nous nous
faisons preuve d'une naïveté coupable
nous ne réagissons pas face à
l'islamisme intégriste
alors qu'il est indispensable de prendre
les mesures qui sont aujourd'hui les
seuls capables de faire cette réaction
au début du 20e siècle quand la france
décide de mettre en place les règles de
la laïcité elle demande à l'église
catholique profondément de s'adapter et
elle prend des mesures qui étaient
parfois des mesures très dures et
aujourd'hui nous sommes incapables face
à l'islamisme intégriste de prendre les
mesures qui s'imposent eh bien nous
demandons qu'on sorte de cette naïveté
ne demandons que soit mis en place un
pacte contre l'islamisme intégriste à
l'échelle européenne qui permette de
prendre les mesures indispensables
d'abord fermer toutes les mosquées
salafistes sur le continent européen
c'est indispensable ensuite interdire
aux imams qui prêchent la haine
chaque vendredi à l'ombre des mosquées
et font leur travail de propagande et de
haine quand un imam presse la haine je
ne comprends pas que la république
continue à l'autoriser à officier chaque
vendredi qu'on sorte de france et
d'europe tous les imams qui prêchent la
haine
on ne peut pas continuer à laisser ces
réseaux se diffuser c'est nous
et enfin s'agissant des jihadistes vous
savez je suis allé à mossoul
j'ai vu ce qu'était la barbarie de dèche
et des djihadistes
j'ai vu le visage de ces familles y dit
qu'ils avaient été transformés en
esclaves sexuelles vendu d'un combattant
dèche à l'autre et qui était revenue
brisé par la souffrance j'ai vu au coeur
de mossoul
cet immeuble où on mettait des gens tout
en haut
en leur voile en la tête pour qu'il ne
voit pas ce qui allait leur arriver et
on les précipitaient pour qu'ils agonise
au pied de l'immeuble avec le cou brisé
pendant des heures et des heures
tout ça parce qu'il n'était pas de la
religion musulmane
j'ai vu ce terrain de foot où les
combattants des shows s'amusait à faire
jouer des gamins de 10 ans au football
avec les têtes décapitées de leur ennemi
j'ai vu des familles au coeur de mossoul
qui ont perdu tous leurs enfants parce
qu'ils étaient chrétiens parce qu'ils
étaient orthodoxe je ne peux pas
imaginer une seule seconde que notre
pays et la naïveté de faire revenir ceux
qui ont commis cette barbarie sur le sol
européen le président de la république
et le gouvernement ont d'ores et déjà
accepté que 200 djihadistes reviennent
en france elles sont déjà revenus stop
que nous faut-il nous nous demandons une
chose très claire que l'europe fasse un
tribunal international
qu'ils soient situés en irak que ce
tribunal international permettent de
juger les djihadistes là où ils ont
commis leur crime qu'il soit condamné là
où ils ont commis leur crime et qu'il
reste là où ils ont commis leur crime
les jihadistes n'ont pas à revenir sur
le sol français et sur le sol européen
et oui arnaud marine le pen déteste
tellement l'europe qu'elle vote même
contre ce qui permet de protéger la
france elle a refusé de voter contre ce
logiciel qui permettait de surveiller
les gens qui embarquait à l'inter des
avions et les terroristes en expliquant
ce qui permet de mesurer à quel point
marine le pen n'est de toute évidence
pas à la hauteur en osant expliqué que
les terroristes ne prennent pas l'avion
mais comment un responsable politique
peut encore dire cela après ce qui s'est
passé le 11 septembre
madame le pen mohamed merah les frères
kwasi avait pris l'avion pour se rendre
en afghanistan et pour se rendre au
yémen
vous êtes irresponsable de tenir de tels
propos dans une époque comme la nôtre
[Applaudissements]
mais je voudrais finir par cela le mal
est plus profond et l'espoir peut-être
la cl on le regarde et qu'on y apporte
les remèdes
vous êtes ici dans une terre de lorraine
admirable qui a été construite par des
flux de populations qui sont venus ici
en venant parfois d'autres pays
européens en venant de pologne en venant
belgique en venant d'italie en venant
d'espagne en venant du portugal en
venant évidemment du sud de la
méditerranée et en venant ici en ayant
ce discours qui a toujours forcé mon
admiration pour leur enfant consistant à
leur dire on vient ici pour travailler
ne me fait pas honte
tiens toi bien respecte ce que te dit le
maître apprend le français apprend à
lire apprend à écrire donne-toi du mal à
compter de ce jour
ton pays c'est la france
ta civilisation c'est la civilisation
européenne cela c'était l'intégration
qui a permis petit à petit de façonner
ce qu'était le visage de la république
française et que s'est-il passé
mais nous avons inversé le devoir
d'intégration nous avons oublié que la
vraie générosité c'est de transmettre ce
que nous sommes nous avons perdu notre
fierté et nous avons cru qu'à cueillir
l'autre sait s'adapter à l'autre alors
que c'est au contraire lui transmettre
ce qu on est pour qu'il puisse faire
sien le pays dans lequel il s'est
installé
quelle erreur nous avons tous été
marqués par l'incendié de notre dame
nous avons tous été marqués par cet
incendie parce que c'était la france qui
brûlait nous avons tous été marqués par
cet incendie parce que soudain était
évident alors que je me suis souvent
battu pour imposer cette idée était
soudain évident que bien évidemment que
les racines de la france est chrétienne
mais il ya des incendies qui sont moins
visibles
il ya des incendies qui sont plus sous
terrain il y a les incendies qui
attirent moins l'attention et qui ronge
de l'intérieur de la même manière notre
civilisation
à chaque fois qu'on accepte que dans une
salle de classe on renonce à un voyage
de classe à reims parce que certains
disent ça n'est pas compatible avec ma
religion 7
un incendie à chaque fois que dans un
quartier une femme n'a plus le choix
2 la façon de s'habiller qu'elle est
obligée de porter le voile parce que
certains intégristes lui impose cette un
incendie à chaque fois que dans un
hôpital un médecin homme se voit la
conte se voit contesté la possibilité
d'intervenir sur une patiente femme
parce qu'on lui explique que dans les
règles de la religion on ne peut pas
faire comme ça 7
un incendie à chaque fois que l'on
recule un peu sur ce que nous sommes
7 un incendie pourquoi je n'ai jamais
voulu lâcher sur ce dossier en apparence
si anodin des crèches
parce que j'ai toujours été convaincu
que les crèches c'est un petit bout de
ce que nous sommes et qu'à chaque fois
que nous faisons un pas en arrière
à chaque fois que nous choisissons le
chemin de la soumission
nous ne construisons pas l'avenir de
notre pays
nous sommes la france nous sommes
l'europe
ici nous sommes en lorraine vous êtes
dans cette terre qui était le joyau du
croisement des grandes routes
commerciales de l' empire romain vous
êtes dans cette terre qui a été édifié
patiemment par des abbayes qui ont
contribué à la défricher et à lui donner
son premier essor économique
vous êtes ici à pont-à-mousson dans une
des premières universités au rayonnement
international qui avait été créé à
l'époque moderne et qui à l'époque forcé
le respect en attirant les talents du
monde
vous êtes dans une terre qui a toujours
été capable d'innover d'entreprendre
d'aller chercher les brevets demain de
construire ce qui forçait le respect par
la qualité de ses manufactures puis
ensuite par la qualité de ses industries
une terre qui a contribué à édifier la
réussite de la révolution industrielle
du 19e siècle et qui avait projeté la
lorraine au coeur de l'europe
vous êtes dans une terre qui a souffert
mais vous êtes dans une terre qui n'a
jamais renoncé
vous êtes ici dans cette ville de
pont-à-mousson qui a été quasiment rasé
au moment de 14-18 par les tirs de
l'artillerie allemande et où les
bibliothèques des moines de prémontré où
tous les vestiges du passé avaient été
réduits à néant
vous êtes dans une terre qui a à nouveau
connu l'outragé du temps avec la seconde
guerre mondiale où elle a à nouveau été
détruites et où la libération de
pont-à-mousson a été fait notamment par
les résistants qui ont contribué à
reconstruire l'avenir de la france dans
cette terre de lorraine qui a donné la
croix de lorraine à l'emblème du
mouvement gaulliste qui a contribué à la
libération de la france et de l'europe
vous êtes dans cette terre où même quand
la chapelle jeanne d'arc avait été
détruite jamais vous n'avez baisser les
bras
vous êtes dans cette terre qu'est plus
qu'aucune autre est resté fidèle au
message du général de gaulle que je
chéris le plus pour faire face à
l'adversité
il fallait que nous restions nous mêmes
fidèle à une conception de l'homme
disait le général de gaulle qui nous a
faits tels que nous sommes faire valoir
dans le tumulte du monde ce que nous
sommes
pour servir et pour survivre de quoi
aurions nous montrent comment ne pas
comprendre que cette histoire est la
meilleure garantie de notre avenir
comment ne pas comprendre que si l'on
veut refonder l'europe rétablir la
france il faut faire les deux à la fois
retrouver la fierté de ce que nous avons
été pour retrouver l'audace de ce que
nous serons comprendre tout simplement
qu'il faut adresser un message qu'ils
soient simples qui était le message de
saint-augustin le devoir d'intégration
ne doit pas être inversée c'est à celui
qui vient chez nous de s'adapter à ce
qu'est notre mode de vie et ça n'est pas
à notre mode de vie de s'adapter à celui
qui vient c'est nous c'est celle
générosité que je veux que nous
retrouvions
refonder le rap rétablir la france est
au nom de ce débat que je vous demande
de vous engager dans cette campagne des
européennes
refonder l'europe rétablir la france
comprendre que cette histoire nous
pouvons tout à la fois en être fier et
que nous devons en être digne comme je
suis consternée quand je vois que dans
cette campagne le seul but du
rassemblement national et de battre
emmanuel macron et que le seul but d'en
mars est de battre le rassemblement
national
eh bien nous nous vous proposons une
toute autre bataille nous nous vous
proposons la seule bataille qui vaille
en politique je n'en connais pas de plus
belle c'est celle qui consiste à
réaffirmer son identité c'est celle qui
consiste à redonner un souffle à sa
civilisation
nous avons besoin de vous il reste une
poignée de jours pour permettre
d'inverser le cours des choses
il reste une poignée de jours pour
transformer cet espoir qui a commencé à
se lever dans cette campagne en une
marée qui ne s'arrêtera plus il reste
une poignée de jours pour redresser les
choses
il reste une poignée de jours pour
porter le débat qui a toujours été le
nôtre sauver tout à la fois ce qu'est
l'identité de notre pays et refonder
l'europe dont nous avons besoin
battez-vous au nom de sa aidez nous nous
avons besoin de vous il reste une
poignée du jour pour réaffirmer la voix
de la droite et du centre dans notre
pays
vive la france et vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]